really nice to be here with all of you
this morning I want to just start by
acknowledging that we are meeting today
under really unusual circumstances and
also in the midst of one of the just a
terrible week one of the most depressing
and disturbing weeks that I can remember
in my adult lifetime so I hope that you
are all safe right now I hope that you
are well right now and I'm glad that
you've made space to to join me today
and talk about power which is always an
important topic but one that really
seems to be highlighted by what's going
on in the world right now so I want to
acknowledge that you know where we're
operating in this difficult context but
I also just want to point out that for
people who are interested in power and
leadership and how just the choices that
leaders make in handling crises that the
last month or so has really provided a
lot of interesting food for thought and
what I want to do today is share with
you some of the I think more interesting
observations that I've made myself just
in hopes that we can get kind of a
deeper understanding of things that we
think we understand already so let me
just start by saying sorry there we go
let me just start by saying that I've
been I'm a psychologist by training
sometimes you know that I've been
studying power for about 25 years now
and the approach that I take to this
topic is different I would say then what
you see in many books in many theories
and and in the ways that people tend to
teach about power and business schools
in particular so there's been an
emphasis forever I think on the idea
that we all need more power
in order to be successful in life and
and the implication of that is that we
should all seek power at every
opportunity at any cost and try to
maintain our competitive advantage over
others in the domain of power and I I
have a number of issues with this
perspective but one of the most
important ones I think is that as a
psychologist one of the things I know is
that in fact more often than not we have
more power than we think we do by virtue
of the roles that we play in life so one
of the interesting really fascinating
things about the human relationship to
power is that we often feel powerless
when we're not and this is true not just
for people who are in you know not in
positions of power but people who are in
positions of power as well and I think
that some of the things that we're
seeing right now with regard to how
different leaders and the police are
responding to protests some of the
reactions suggest to me that the people
who are in charge of protecting us are
out of touch actually with how much
power they already have in the situation
in our over compensating the ways that I
don't make sense so my my approach has
always been to ask you know managers and
leaders of all kinds people who lead
teams who run organizations who are
parents to consider the possibility that
and you already have more power than you
think you do and in terms of you wanting
to meet your goals in life and and have
success what really matters is the
choices that you make about how to use
the power you have so that's what I want
to talk with you about today I'm going
to make some observations about the
choices that I see being made in the
world right now and and what I think
they indicate and whether I think
they're effective or not
so when it comes to thinking about power
and how we use it I just want to mention
a couple things so just forget the sake
of definition power is the
to which we have the capacity to control
other people and to make them do things
despite their resistance that's what
power is and it has many sources
sometimes it comes in the form of formal
Authority sometimes it comes in the form
of weapons that we made there sometimes
it comes in the form of sadist some
extent which other people respect us and
need our approval so there are many
sources of power and what I want to
suggest is that independent of how much
power any of us has in a given situation
we make choices every day in terms of
our behavior and how we respond to the
challenges that we face on these two
dimensions that you're looking at here
so first of all we make decisions
everyday when interacting with other
people about whether to play our
power-up
that is to talk about the vertical
dimension on this graph now so we make
choices about whether to play our power
up to remind people that we're in charge
to throw our weight around to let people
know that we have our hands on the wheel
and that we're the deciders sometimes we
decide to advertise our power I call
that you know playing power up and
sometimes we make the choice to play our
power down so we make the choice to
camouflage our power or to hide our
power or to just reassure people that we
don't intend to use the power we have
against them and I call that powering
down so these are choices that we see
you know we all make every day in
organizations I spend lots of time
talking with people about the choices
they're making them and whether they're
whether they're right or wrong and the
other dimension that that matters in
terms of choosing which of these
approaches to take is on the horizontal
dimension on the scrap and it has to do
with what you think powers for so you
can choose to play your power up or play
it down because you think you need to
protect or enhance yourself or because
you think it's your responsibility
to protect other people and this is
another place I think where my approach
to power is different from maybe what a
lot of people assume if you look out in
the world especially in Western culture
I would say we have a tendency to think
of power as a resource for personal
enhancements looks like a prize it's an
accomplishment it's something that we
try to acquire and it's a you know as an
indicator of our value and our worth to
society but if you look at the way power
exists in the natural world if you look
at animals and human groups what you see
is that power exists in a context and
within groups we conspire to give some
members more power than others and we do
that in hopes that those people will use
their special rights and privileges to
protect the rest of us so in my mind
when you look at power in its natural
you know in its natural habitat I'm
reminded all the time that the purpose
of power is not just self aggrandizement
and personal advancement it's really to
protect the people who are agreeing and
conspiring to give us special rights and
privileges so bottom line here we have a
lot of choices we can make independent
of the power we have you can choose to
play power up you can choose to play it
down you can do it in ways that are
designed to protect yourself in your own
position or you can do it in ways that
are designed to enhance and protect the
groups that you belong to and I want to
make the case today that to be affected
with power to use power well you want to
do everything you can to stay in the
northeast side of this diagonal that
we're all maximally effective at using
power when we are using power to protect
the interests of people who are more
vulnerable than we are and that's the
sort of overarching perspective that I
want to bring to bear on this
conversation today so to use power well
we want to bring both strengths
compassion to the table and one of the
big questions in the management
literature things that executives
struggle with all the time is which of
these should you lead with so knowing
that you want to both show strength and
show respect and compassion to others
what are the conditions under which it
makes sense to lead with strength and
what are the conditions in which it
makes sense to lead with compassion and
just two weeks ago seems like a lifetime
ago this is where we were and this is
where I was in terms of my thinking
about what I was learning from the
pandemic so one of the things that I
observed that was so interesting in the
news coverage of how different leaders
have responded to the pandemic and those
who were receiving praise is that in
contrast to the idea that we see in the
management literature right now which is
that leaders should always emphasize
should leave its compassion should be
vulnerable should play their power down
in every way possible the leaders who
have been you know highlighted and
praised of having been most effective
during the pandemic actually I believe
led with strength and I say this because
what I noticed about them and of course
when you look at this picture the first
thing you notice is there is that
they're all women so you know yay for
that it's the first time I've ever seen
anything like this but what I think is
more instructive and more interesting
right now is kind of what what did these
leaders do they acted early to use their
authority to impose control in the
countries where they're in charge to
absorb the political risk of making very
unpopular decisions to protect the
health and safety of the people who
depend on them so I think of this as a
very authoritative approach actually to
using power and it's in contrast to what
we've seen in a lot of other countries
where the crisis has been much worse in
terms of public health outcomes where
leaders decided to let citizens decide
for themselves how they wanted to
respond to the threat of the virus and
and in my mind what that was doing is
pushing the risk down so that leaders
didn't have to make any unpopular
decisions that would hurt them later
politically and I think it's interesting
to notice we often think of the idea of
using strengths
we're leading with strength it's not
terribly popular in our current dialogue
it seems old-fashioned it seems
autocratic and paternalistic but one of
the things I'm reminded of by these
events that we've been observing over
the last month or two is that there is a
time and place for owning and using
one's authority in a strong way and what
we know from research is that
specifically in times of maximum
uncertainty when people population
citizens employees children feel
maximally powerless and hopeless tend to
prefer and gravitate toward strong
leadership and so I'm just showing you
data here from an interesting study that
was published a couple years ago that
collected data surveyed about 160,000
people in 69 countries and correlated
the economic conditions within a country
actually I think some of these were
countries some were studies done in
organizations the conditions of economic
uncertainty were correlated with the
extent to which people preferred a more
dominant or autocratic leader as opposed
to one that was more participative or
more democratic and what you see here is
that the more economic uncertainty
people are experiencing in terms of
poverty in terms of unemployment in
terms of uncertainty about the future
the more they tend to really need
reassurance from strong leaders and this
is why we've actually seen you know over
the last decade or so rise in you know
very autocratic populist leaders around
the country
being elected in context where economic
conditions are especially dire so it's
important for any of us to be
comfortable with the idea of playing our
power up and using you know leading with
strengths and strengths especially in
context crisis conditions where people
feel maximally uncertain so what I want
to do next
before I change gears and talk about the
limitations on this observation which
has become very very clear in the past
week or so it's just talk to you about
three specific things I think that any
of us can do to nudge ourselves in the
direction of getting more comfortable
owning our own authority and leading
with strength in times of uncertainty
when people need this from us on argued
if these three things are the first one
is seize the spotlight the second one is
phone your decisions and the third one
is to physically spread out so let me
just say a little bit about each of
these in terms of owning or seizing the
spotlight
it's very common I've noticed with
executives to hesitate to put themselves
front and center when the world seems to
be falling apart especially when they
feel that they don't have answers and
when people are really suffering I think
it's not uncommon for leaders to feel
that inserting themselves into the most
personal and intimate kinds of distress
could be perceived as an imposition or
some kind of strange entitlement but
what I think you can see by having
watched what's gone on during the
pandemic is that there are a number of
leaders who have received a lot of
praise for having seized the spotlight
in a particular way and you know
Governor Cuomo is one of them he's had
his daily briefings one of the things
that I think is so interesting about
this is you know he shows up every day
he's got his little feel on he's got the
flags around him there's he kind of
understands the theater of it he doesn't
always have a lot to say in terms of
information that most of us need to know
in fact one of my favorite things about
watching what
happened with the governor during the
pandemic is that there are people from
all over the world who are tuning in to
to watch him in his briefings and it's
not because we need to know what he has
to say it's because we need the
reassurance of seeing that someone is in
charge and this is why seizing the
spotlight is important there are other
examples of this that we've seen the
Prime Minister of Norway held a press
conference just for children
she received a lot of praise for that
and this is the chief medical officer in
South Korea who again has done daily
briefings to share all the information
that she has but just showing up every
single day reminds people when they feel
at their most insecure that there are
people who are in charge that they're
calm under pressure and that they have
got their eye on the ball and they're
doing everything they can to protect to
protect the rest of us this is an
example that will hit close to home for
many of us this is Mary Barra who's a
GSB alum she's the CEO of General Motors
right now and has tended to take a very
low-key out of the spotlight approach to
her leadership she's in a huge role but
does not tend to seek out publicity in
general but she really sees the moment
when you know in terms of pivoting the
entire company to start producing
ventilators because the the country
needed them and since having done that
has appeared in the news almost every
day in photos like this one where she's
just showing herself in the middle of
what's happening that she's got an eye
on it that she's in charge and that
there the General Motors is acting on
behalf of the country so I think she's
done this very effectively and one of
the things I admire the most about her
in this particular picture is that she's
using power so well that she actually
got vice president pence to wear a mask
in this picture so anyway seizing the
spotlight is useful it's a useful way of
thinking about powering up and owning
your authority
you may feel sheepish about it I'm here
to tell you that people who
insecure when you are the person in
charge need to see more of you not less
even if you don't have answers and don't
know what you're gonna say and what are
the other things that I coach executives
on a lot is this challenge in particular
which is how to get yourself into the
right frame of mind to show up in public
and to actually take people's time and
ask them to to be there to witness when
you aren't really sure that you have
anything useful to tell them
and so I remind people that you can get
yourself in the right frame of mind
sometimes by just giving yourself a few
minutes before you go on to to to take
control of what you're paying attention
to and what where your imagination is
going and this mantra is something that
I have coached a lot of people to use
something that you would say to yourself
before going into any high-stakes
situation where you're going to be in
the spotlight which is you may not know
everything but what you're glad to be
there and you know what you know so some
of you may find that useful in dealing
with the challenges that you're facing
right now the second thing I want to
talk about is this challenge of owning
our decisions you know it's not so much
a question of making decisions on our
own but rather making ourselves visibly
accountable for the decisions that we're
making as a way of owning our authority
and powering up the prime minister of
New Zealand has received a lot of kudos
for this this is an interesting picture
of her because what you can see is she's
surrounded by all of her advisers but
she's standing in front of them owning
the decisions that she's making and
holding herself accountable for the
consequences so here's another this is a
YouTube video that she put out where she
shows herself consulting with her chief
scientists but always make sure to take
personal responsibility for the
decisions that she's made that have had
harsh consequences for others and I want
to just say by way of a broad framework
in terms of thinking about this idea
like in a leadership role when thinking
about how to use
our to what extent should you be making
decisions on your own under pressure
versus involving others and being more
participated or giving them shared
ownership of decisions and often as
leaders when we're tasked with using
power we tend to think of our selves as
really having only these two options
that are like on the end you know the
extreme ends of this particular scale
that we can make the decisions on our
own or we can involve everyone and
delegate responsibilities away but what
I like about this model that I'm sharing
with you and some of you may remember
this from classes that I've taught is
that it reminds us that we actually have
a lot of options in terms of how to use
power and balance between being totally
autocratic and authoritative in our
decision-making and totally consultative
so I would want to suggest that in a
situation like this one where you really
want to be somewhere in the middle of
this scale so you're in a situation
where you are aware of all the things
you don't know you're consulting with
experts to make sure that you have all
the relevant information but you are
taking personal responsibility and
accountability for the decisions that
you're making and owning that yourself
and I just wanted to share this example
I thought this was a great example of
how an executive has done this during
the crisis so this is Henry Ward who's
the CEO of Carter who sent this message
to his employees to a company layoffs
that he had to enact and basically what
he says in the letter is that he
personally reviewed every single list of
potential layoffs every single person
and if the person who's reading the
email was one of those affected it was
because he made the decision because
your manager did not make the
recommendation more often than not your
managers fought to keep you so you
shouldn't blame them if today's your
last day I'm the person to blame
just a way again of owning owning our
authority so owning our decisions is the
second one and the third one that I want
to talk with you about is this notion of
spreading out so some of you will know
that my approach to using power relies a
lot on understanding how people and
other kinds of animals negotiate power
in the real world and most of this is
done through our nonverbal signaling
about who has power and what our
intentions are in terms of how we intend
to use it so let me just say a couple
things you've probably seen this before
I think Amy Cuddy's work publicized this
idea popularize the idea that expansive
postures are associated with power
I must interested in how they affect our
own psychology but much more interested
in how they affect how other people
respond to us and I think this picture
is amazing so you were looking at
Christine Lagarde here who is the head
of the European Central Bank and what's
amazing is you can see in this
photograph I don't think any of these
particular political leaders was paying
attention to how they were using their
body but it's amazing how much more
authoritative and in charge she and more
like a leader she appears than the men
that she's surrounded by who are sitting
I think the way many of us do when we're
not paying attention to how we're
sitting which is to especially under
crisis conditions we have a tendency to
kind of fold in ourselves so the
shoulders are more rounded their hands
are between their knees and what you can
see that I think is really notable about
how she appears is how open her chest is
so she's much more open her shoulders
are back and she's actually using her
arms to expand her footprint a little
bit which is what it means to be
expansive and to demonstrate your own
status and authority I have a couple of
other pictures like this I wanted to
share and I'm focusing here on mostly
things that happen above the waist
because we're all one boom now very
interesting to notice how people use
their arms and hands when thinking about
power this is an example of you know
Prime Minister Trudeau of Canada was one
of the first world leaders to figure out
how to deal with president Trump's very
dominant and aggressive handshake and
the way he did it was to extend his arm
and go into the president's face before
the president had a chance to invade his
space so anytime that you allow your
arms and hands to leave your body it is
suggest that you kind of own the space
and the turf that you're in and I
encourage you to experiment with using
your harm arms and hands and
authoritative ways another great example
of this I don't want to spend too much
time on it is how Nancy Pelosi uses her
arms and hands I think she's a master of
understanding the relationship between
her nonverbal behavior her body language
and her authority and there are just a
couple of examples I think her daughter
referred to what she does as Italian
grandmother move and I love that I love
that description so she you know you can
see her tearing up the State of the
Union address very publicly pointing
standing and pointing at the president
so pointing is a very authoritative way
to use your hand open palms as I'm going
to talk about in just a minute it's a
much lot more disarming less
authoritative way to use your hands and
also she used her hand to quiet down the
Congress when they were getting unruly
so if you're interested in learning more
about how to use your hands and arms to
convey Authority I encourage you to
check out Nancy Pelosi here's the last
thing on being expansive and spreading
out I remind especially young company
founders often that there are nonverbal
ships that have to occur when you're
moving from being the person who was the
you know the content expert to becoming
a head of a company and I remind people
that it's important not just to think of
spreading out in terms of your arms and
your chest but also in terms of the
length of your spine
it's I'll encourage you to do this right
now if you imagine that you have a heavy
headdress on your head right now
just notice what that does to the rest
of your body so if you imagine yourself
in a heavy crown or a large pot of some
kind what you'll find is that it has a
tendency to naturally elongate your
spine to lift your chin a little bit and
to make sure that your head stays stable
and still on top of your shoulders which
is also a way of spreading out in
showing Authority so these are three
things anyone can do in a circumstance
where the people who depend on you need
greater reassurance to own your
authority and power up this is and this
is what I was thinking about last week
here's where we are this week and I'm
compelled to say that obviously there
are caveats to the the advice that I'm
giving and I want to try to put in
theoretical context why using strength
is advisable in the way that I just
described in the context I just
described but it's not necessarily the
best approach to dealing with the
protests that we've seen so this is
where we are you see a lot of the police
forces again having to make this choice
about whether to lead with strength and
dominance to throw their weight around
and remind people that they that they're
wearing that they're wearing done as
though we needed any reminder or making
the decision to power down make them
feel less intimidating as a way of
trying to disarm fearful and angry
protesters who are rising up so this is
the this is the what we see when we see
the police leading with strength taking
a commanding control approach to dealing
with the protesters what you'll notice
is that the violence tends to escalate
and what we've started to see more
recently is this opposite approach which
any so
force any police officer and any person
to position power can take which is to
basically signal in every way possible
that although you are in a position of
power and authority you do not intend to
use your power and authority to harm
anyone else and this is actually you
just incredible to look at the contrast
in terms of how different political
leaders and police are taking these
these two different approaches and what
the consequences are so here we see
again this choice in a crisis but a
slightly different context between
whether to take a commanding control
approach that involves leading with
strength and powering up versus taking a
more respect and connect approach which
is more associated with powering down
and I'm going to make the case that this
is this is a context when you see a
fearful populace talk to anger rising up
and seeking respect and validation that
powering down is going to be the better
approach in terms of restoring
equilibrium and maintaining harmony in
the peaceful context so it's very
interesting what I'm going to suggest is
that when others are rising up it makes
much more sense to power down and what
this illustrates for any of us who
worried about the idea of showing
deference of bowing down of taking off
all our armor and even potentially
showing vulnerability and fear and
weakness ourselves is that we worry that
it'll be exploited and that people will
take advantage of us but often this is
not the case often what ends up
happening is that we just end up showing
respect to people who are beneath us in
the power structure which is in large
part what helps to disarm their their
anger so it's really interesting and
there are a lot of psychological
principles to explain why both of these
approaches can be the right approach to
take as a short short hand what
say about it is that there is this
complementarity principle that exists in
the research on on the psychology of
social hierarchies which showed that
really interesting almost every
dimension you can think of similarity
tends to attract people will be drawn to
others and have positive feelings about
others based on similarity the only
exception to that rule is the vertical
dimension is the hierarchical dimension
where opposites tend to attract when
people want to cooperate and get along
with one another what studies show is
that they tend to prefer interactions
with people who respond to their power
moves in a complementary fashion so when
in the first case there's a population
that feels helpful that submissive
that's hiding that's begging for someone
to tell them what to do the generous
thing to do is to power up and show
strength and take the reins and be the
person in charge but when you're dealing
with someone who is making a bid for
power seeking respect and validation
showing anger the generous thing to do
is to power down is to let them know
that you is to respond to them by saying
I can give you I can give you some some
latitude I can share my power with you
in this circumstance to maintain the
harmony in our relationship so opposites
tend to attract on the vertical
dimension and this explains why both of
these approaches can make sense if you
think about it I like to remind people
when thinking about the idea of powering
down about the principles of secure
based leadership this comes from a
researcher who developed a theory of
leadership based on his experience as a
hostage negotiator so his experience
comes from dealing with the challenge of
disarming angry and fearful hostage
takers
and he talks about how important it is
to power down and to basically engage in
active listening show compassion show
empathy and validate the hostage-takers
point of view as a way of defusing the
situation so in a couple minutes that we
have left let me just say a few things
that I've noticed about how leaders in
the context of these racial injustice
protests have successfully powered down
along the same lines of or really just
the opposite of what I talked about
earlier I'm gonna suggest that the way
we use our hands have a huge impact in
terms of what we're signaling to others
about our intentions in terms of how we
use power active listening is incredibly
important in fact it's the most
important thing when it comes to dealing
with angry with angry and fearful people
and instead of instead of spreading out
I'm going to suggest that it's very
important to literally stand down and do
things to make your physical footprint
smaller as a way of being less
threatening when you're the person in
charge and I'll just show a couple of
pictures here because I want to make
sure we have a time to time to get to
questions you know the the protesters if
their hands up don't shoot our showing
the meaning the symbolic meeting of open
hands and we know from research on
generosity and warmth that when people
are feeling love in their hearts toward
others they have a tendency to open
their palms so if you think of strength
as being associated with a closed fist
generosity and compassion are associated
with open palms so we see this here and
the protesters what we've started to see
or what I've started to notice more is
how police officers and leaders are
using their hands to connect with angry
protesters as a way of defusing violence
so you can see the open palms in this
picture I think it's interesting also
that the eyes are closed so direct
is very threatening closing your eyes is
also a way of disarming and powering
down this is another I think great
example of what I'm talking about here
you can see the open palms it's it's a
generous offering it's almost like a
willingness to hold someone and this
police officer also kneeling down I
think this is really important
the second thing has to do with active
listening I was so shocked when I saw
the police chief in Atlanta she was the
first leader I saw doing it walking into
the protests without any protection and
just listening to the protesters and
listening to what they were feeling and
what they were experiencing and just
absorbing it and letting them know that
she heard them and that she was with
them those protests have been mostly
peaceful I think because of the approach
that that she has taken or when she's
taken that approach and we've seen it in
other cases as well so just the idea of
listening and I think it's important
because as you know someone who it's
very difficult I think sometimes to know
how to be a good ally in a situation
where there are protests against racial
injustice because we don't really know
what to say if we haven't had this
personal experience what I think is
really important to take away from this
is that listening is probably more
important than speaking at this point
and it's and it's easier so the idea of
opening your ears and opening your heart
I think is super important and then the
last one I just mentioned standing down
taking a knee is symbolic in the sense
that it is reducing your footprint you
can't really effectively use physical
force in this position it's part of the
reason that it has the effect that it
does and here are other examples of
people in positions of power
standing down and making their footprint
smaller as a way of trying to to show
that they're not a threat and to disarm
disarmed the the anger and aggression
and have these confrontations and
conflicts resolved peacefully as
as opposed to violently so I want to
stop and take questions but basically
what I've tried to do is to lay out this
space for you in terms of the choices we
all make every day in our rules when we
are in positions of power we we make
these choices all the time I want to
also point out that what I think of as
the main determinant that keeps us on
the right side of this diagonal has to
do with how effectively we manage our
sphere and people often assume
wrongfully that when we're in positions
of power we are not afraid power holders
are just as afraid as everyone else
they're afraid that they don't have as
much power as they do and this is in
large part what leads to more
self-protective more hostile and
aggressive reaction to conflicts and
confrontation I just try to encourage
people all the time to remember that the
purpose of power is to protect other
people try to open your heart try to
open your ears and stand with people who
need you in these circumstances as
opposed to worrying about protecting
yourself so let me stop there thank you
for your attention and I'm happy to take
questions and look forward to hearing
your reactions perfect so we have a
couple of questions about the
complementarity principle slide and you
had suggested aiming for the northwest
corner there's questions about what
exhibitionistic really means and should
you be aiming for that how does that
really fit yeah so I think I hope I
didn't say Northwest I might have I met
northeast it's the upper right hand
quadrant that I think we want to aim for
so the thing about exhibitionist is
think of it like extraversion so
extroverts have an advantage over
introverts because they signal that
they're friendly
and being exhibitionist has a has a
similar quality if you think of the
opposite as hiding out so one of the
things that we often do that
inadvertently signals that were kind of
aloof hostile not totally with other
people is we withdraw and we get stuck
in our own heads and we hide out in that
way whenever we're thinking about things
and not 100% present it reads cool and
aloof so showing up and showing off has
the advantage of signaling to other
people that you want to be with them and
that's what I meant by that and so
speaking about the question about
spreading out how do we translate that
to remote constant context since we're
working Dutch absolutely so it's very
interesting you know and it depends on
really you know what you want to
emphasize it's hard when you're in a
zoom Square to figure out how to send
all the signals that you want to send so
one of the things that I have noticed
when I'm paying attention to like when
I'm in a meeting and looking at everyone
in their own domain is that there are
people who are very close to the screen
and I like I am right now so I'll get a
little bit closer even I think what this
does is it's making it a very open and
very present and very I hope connected
to audience what I see a lot of people
doing that is more associated with the
notion of powering up and being
authoritative is taking more distance
facing the camera indirectly sometimes I
even see this online
and and being spread out in this way one
of the things that I've noticed that
kind of makes me laugh again I'm not
recommending this but I just want to
observe it that there are people who
when they're sitting in like a throne
type of chair it just enhances the whole
thing because the the chair actually
expands the footprint as well so and we
notice about props and costumes you know
people wear crowns and capes and collars
as a way of taking up more space than
their physical body does I've seen
people use chairs and and the space in
their rooms to do that as well so it's a
little bit hard to do what I would say
is that even if you can't see someone's
entire body I think you can get I think
it reads differently if I'm sitting like
this then if I'm sitting like this so
you can open you can open your chest and
I think it will affect a lot of the
things that people are able to see and
also the notion of using our hands or
something I think we can use on screen
most people don't but I think we could
oh we could if we were more mindful
about it well if something can connect
it to that we have a question about the
sincerity of the gestures do people
instantly recognize where their gesture
is genuine annoyed or not if you are you
know trying to convey power through
gestures yeah so here's an interesting
thing there are two aspects to sincerity
and authenticity right there there's the
question of how it feels to us when
we're doing something that feels
unnatural that's one issue and I would
encourage all of you who are in
leadership positions for the moment when
thinking about power to worry less about
that so it is important even if you're
not someone who normally sees with the
spotlight even if you're not someone who
normally you know is very authoritative
in the way they will they will power if
it's what's necessary I encourage you to
do it anyway the people who work
for you will welcome it if it meets
their needs so that's the first thing I
would say in terms of the sincerity on
the other dimension here's what I can
tell you the behaviors associated with
powering up if they're done with
commitments are taken at face value we
tend to defer to dominant people without
even being aware that we're doing it
it's almost like a survival instinct and
like I mentioned earlier with that
complementarity principle most of us
understand if we want to maximize
cooperation and connection and provide a
sense of security for the person that
we're dealing with the natural thing to
do is to respond to someone else's
nonverbal behavior with the opposite so
people tend to take the dominance and
submissiveness choose at face value I
think no one asks whether that's their
sincere or not they tend to go under the
radar it's almost like we have a very
primitive part of our brain response to
that in terms of the other dimension the
compassion the connection that's harder
to fake and what I would suggest to
people I didn't say it explicitly but
I'll say it explicitly now is that you
have to find a way to focus your
attention on things that will naturally
open your heart and your mind to other
people you have to be thinking not about
the ways that someone might hurt you not
about the ways that someone might judge
you which i think is how a lot of us
often think going into these situations
but rather thinking about the things you
appreciate about others the reasons
you're happy to be with them the good
things that could come out of the
interaction if you can focus your
attention on positive things your heart
will open and then
if you're smiling and showing compassion
and leaving in it will be sincere
actually so it's just a question with
that one really of making sure that
you're paying attention to where your
attention goes so that your mindset and
your feelings make it possible for you
to show compassion in a innocent Seir
way Thanks
we have a couple of questions asking how
the matrix changes or how you apply the
matrix changes when identity constructs
are taken into account such as gender or
age or you know if you're from a
different culture yeah how does that
play into it I guess the question has to
do with whether the same choices make
sense for all different kinds of people
under different circumstances I'm going
to take a fairly radical position and
say that for the most part I don't think
the identity characteristics matter as
much as we think we do with regard to
what I'm talking about today and I'll
give you some caveats but what's really
important in terms of making a choice to
power up or to power down is that the
people you're dealing with
believe you're making that choice to
serve their interest and whether you're
a man or a woman whether you're you know
a marginal member of a group or a
high-status member of a group when you
behave in ways that clearly are that are
clearly useful and add value to the
group in the moment where you do it
everybody gets credit for doing that
it's a gift where what we don't like is
when it appears that people are powering
up or powering down because they think
it's best for them I think it's the best
way to keep themselves safe or to
protect their own position and everybody
gets punished for that actually it's not
you know some groups get punished more
than others so this is one important
caveat
you know very interesting on gender
differences in power there's a lot of
research that shows that in most ways
women take a bigger risk when showing
strength and assertiveness so I want to
say two things about that
the first one is I just want you to
remember the first news headline that I
showed which is that it was actually
women leaders around the globe being
celebrated for their response to Kobe 19
because of the strength that they showed
and the control that they impose there's
one remind you of that but the second
thing is to say what we know from
research is that women get punished
people don't like them when they are
verbally assertive when they engage in
verbal verbal arguments when they try to
you know win fight through conversation
masking men can get away with that more
easily than women but in the non verbal
dimensions the ones like the ones I was
just talking about interestingly there's
no difference actually between how men
and women are perceived when they're
assertive and when they use dominance as
an instrument of power so again it's
like it's like the nonverbal stuff seems
to pass under the radar you respond to
someone intuitively based on whether you
want to cooperate with them or not just
just as a response to what they do with
their bodies without taking into account
things like why is a woman being
physically expansive why is a woman
using our hand in this aggressive way so
so that's I think a very interesting
thing for women to to realize is that
the nonverbal indicators of dominance
and power do not incite the same type of
backlash as the verbal ones do we have
quite a number of questions just about
what's going on around the country why
might you think that some police forces
would just not be open to this approach
where are the barriers for people in
power to to take the side of compassion
yeah I can tell you based on research if
you look at let's say abuses of power
across the board and physical violence
what you tend to see is that when people
have power but feel powerless that's
when they get violent so just to give
you a couple of examples from research
on child abuse parents who feel
incompetent and powerless in terms of
their ability to control their children
are more likely to physically abuse
their children bosses who feel
incompetence who feel like they aren't
respected are more likely to bully
others and I would guess that the same
principals hold that really just has to
do with feelings of weakness while in a
position of power you know not that just
from a power point of view I'm not
commenting on the on the racism aspect
of it right now
so one last quick question if we can
squeeze it in in just a minute or two an
interesting question about that first
slide with women leaders on almost all
of them are smiling in their photo can
you comment and well that's about
because photos of male leaders hardly
ever have such Pleasant smiles that's a
great question there's so many
interesting things that's a really good
observation so the one possibility is
that that was the editor's choice you
know you you could you could have chosen
a lot of photographs of some women
leaders I mean I
showed you one of the police chief in
Atlanta that was not was not smiling so
it's a very interesting question did the
you know was that an editorial choice
because we do feel better about women
when they're smiling and it's also
possible that that women leaders just
smile more and women do smile more than
men in general and there's been research
on this probably won't surprise you
research on smiling I think it's
fascinating and smiling is a very
interesting appeasement behavior it's
it's an act of submission actually
animals do this - some of you may have
those crazy dogs that smile and they
think they're in trouble that we see on
YouTube all the time so what happens
when you have a status or during in
society as we do well women tend to have
less status and power than men this is
just a fact of life
the lower ranking individuals have a
responsibility
according to hierarchical dorms to make
sure that no one above them is ever
uncomfortable and to signal that they're
non-threatening at every opportunity and
that's what smiling does so what you
tend to find in the research is that in
within groups lower ranking group
members smile more than higher ranking
group members and it's not because life
is better at the bottom it's because the
people at the bottom understand that
part of the way they stay safe is to
remind others that they do not intend to
use whatever power they have against
other people that they're not a threat
to the status quo so it is the case that
women smile more I don't know that
anyone has ever looked at leaders in
particular and and I guess that's really
all I have on that on that question
which is a great one I'm gonna be
thinking about it when we're done with
this call that's fascinating
I just want
thank you for joining me today with so
much else going on in the world and and
I wish all of you the best I hope you
stay stay safe and stay well